bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
de samsung une fois n'est pas coutume on
va parler des futurs samsung galaxy note
9 et s 10 1 qui va arriver en fin
d'année loeb qui arrivera en début
d'année prochaine si tout va bien
moralement ça va le faire et vous allez
au basket mais une fonctionnalité hyper
attendu qui va arriver sur probablement
ces deux produits c'est hyper cool
d'aller voir on en parle maintenant
dès qu'on parle de samsung forcément
tout le monde s'affole c'est pareil pour
apple c'est vraiment les deux marques
phares au niveau de la téléphonie mobile
très forte également sur d'autres
segments que ce soit sur des ordinateurs
des tablettes d'autres choses également
mais là pour le coup peut-être les
samsung on devrait voir arriver dès
cette fin d'année une nouvelle
fonctionnalité qui devrait arriver aussi
l'année prochaine sur le s10 et là sur
le net neuf le s10 devrait être le
modèle avec une vraie innovation c'est
vrai que samsung sort un modèle phare
tous les deux ans le et suit avec son
écran infiniti un nouveau design
complètement repensé bord à bord a
vraiment fait parler de lui
le s9 est une évolution alors c'est vrai
qu'il a quand même un point
d'amélioration très très fort du point
de vue de la photo avec cette lentille
ouverture variable ça très clairement
c'est un point qui est vraiment top
on aurait pu retrouver effectivement sur
un modèle hyper novateur d'ailleurs se
laisse neuf séances acmé novateur mais
sur le s10 on devrait avoir un produit
encore plus sexy de point de vue
esthétique avec plein d'autres
fonctionnalités puisque effectivement
comme je le disais tous les deux ans à
samsung sort un modèle fort et au milieu
il ya un produit qui est plus une
évolution qu'une révolution mais en tout
cas c'est tout en premier super cool
donc ce x10 devrait frapper très fort
avec plein de nouvelles choses plein de
nouvelles fonctionnalités un nouveau
design mais ça à rester connectés parce
qu'on va en parler très très très
prochainement il ya plein de choses à
dire dessus et le note 9 aussi devrait
avoir une fonctionnalité qu'on devrait
retrouver sur le s10 l'année prochaine
et une fonctionnalité qui vraiment me
faire parler d'elle
parce que l'idée si vous voulez d'un
constructeur sont déjà devant leur
smartphone mais pour les vendre et pour
occuper l'avant de la scène et qu'on
parle toujours de il faut forcément
proposer des choses hyper innovantes
là on va pas d'une fonctionnalité qui
est à la fois innovante qui a déjà été
vu ailleurs mais pas sur un produit de
samsung et l'est encore moins sur un
produit de chez apple c'est le site
coréen veut bel qui nous apprend que
samsung aurait finalisé
l'écran de cs 10 et s10 plus à savoir
des écrans de 5,8 pouces pour lui es10
et 6,3 pose pour le s10 plus alors
quelles fonctionnalités vont équiper ces
nouveaux écrans j'ai fait un peu le
roulement de tambour je dise justice
bêtise
je lâche le truc c'est tout simplement
un capteur d'empreintes digitales
directement intégré à l'écran
parce que effectivement le lecteur
d'empreintes digitales et est toujours
positionné à l'arrière sur la suite à
gauche je dis pas de bêtises à gauche
oui effectivement dû de la lentille de
l'appareil photo on lui a reproché cette
position parce que on allait souvent un
petit peu trop flirté avec l'appareil
photo ils ont laissé les fameuses traces
de doigts a vendu à 8 et jusqu'aux os 9
qu'on a pu avoir actuellement ils l'ont
positionné dessous mais c'est pas non
plus complètement idéal l'idée
effectivement et ça serait de supprimer
de la face arrière et de le positionner
à la face avant directement sous l'écran
avec un écran qui occuperait quasiment
la totalité de la face avant et avec
l'équipement votre lecteur d'empreintes
digitales positionner directement sous
l'écran alors effectivement il ya des
constructeurs qui le font il ya d'autres
fabricants qui le proposent dans leurs
smartphones mais dans les smartphones
très haut de gamme comme apple samsung
et huawei on n'a pas encore retrouvé
jusqu'à présent alors les rumeurs
feraient également état d'une caméra 3d
un peu comme le fils saadi la caméra
trou d'aix d'apple on pourrait
effectivement retrouvé un déverrouillage
directement en faisant un happening du
visage d'utilisateurs actuellement
samsung propose effectivement un
déverrouillage de la reconnaissance du
visage et de l'iris néanmoins on n'a pas
de mapping en trois dimensions donc avec
une image une photo il est possible de
contourner la sécurité
on retrouvera également ce capteur
d'empreintes digitales sur l'écran des
le note 9 qui arriverait là au deuxième
semestre 2018 donc ça c'est vraiment
intéressant et ça montre la capacité de
samsung à vouloir frapper fort
régulièrement le rassurez vous un pour
le s10 aura plein d'autres choses
y'a pas que ce point là c'est un point
qu'on connaît dès aujourd'hui c'est très
intéressant meilleur aussi plein
d'autres fonctionnalités et alou qui
sera probablement encore repenser
d'autant plus que samsung travaille
également sur ses smartphones pliable le
fameux galaxy x dont on a beaucoup parlé
on a aussi parlé de tablette pliable
avec plusieurs points qui se plie enfin
vous allez voir tout ça on va en parler
très régulièrement parce qu'il ya plein
de choses hyper passionnante à dire là
dessus à savoir que le note 9 dès la fin
de l'année aurait une batterie booster
de 4000 milliampères heures alors vous
allez me dire des batteries et catherine
millot paire eur il y en a déjà regardé
le réseau fon qui est une batterie de
4000 millions terreur mais c'est vrai
que samsung et sa gamme note marche un
peu sur des oeufs
le no27 avait un vrai fiasco avec une
batterie
exploser littéralement bas ou la
batterie pt du coup il n'existe plus
d'ailleurs j'ai pu voir au mwc
une présentation un peu revival de tous
les smartphones de samsung vous avez des
tout premiers gagnants jusqu'au 8 9 11
disque arrivera l'année prochaine et
vous avez la no6 la note 8 et la note 7
n'existe plus elle n'est même plus
présente et c'est vraiment l'enfant
désavoué de samsung donc là
effectivement l'idée avec 7,9 d'avoir
une vaste rice surboosté qui permettrait
de dire on s'est planté avec le note 7
on a bien réussi une note 8 est là avec
le note 9 on revient avec une batterie
très forte alors que c'est justement la
batterie qui allait provoquer les poser
problème avec notre set donc on va
vraiment la capacité à samsung de
rebondir avec des produits très fort
d'absorber un petit peu d'apprendre de
leur échec et d'être toujours plus
innovants aux travaux qui nous vient des
vannes blast le galaxy note 9 pourrait
porter le nom de code de crohn qui veut
dire couronne en français me demandez
pas pourquoi je ne sais pas c'est une
dénomination interne
donc on sait pas exactement comment
s'appellera se note 9 probablement le
galaxy note ne va pas se mentir il va
pas avoir un petit sobriquet un petit
peu un petit peu bizarre sortis de
derrière les fagots
par contre ce qui est très intéressant
c'est de poser la question du s10 cette
dénomination s'est déjà posé la question
d'ailleurs pour apple
la dénomination des iphone 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
voilà unique 9/10 un moment nous paraît
un peu désuet le nom va probablement
changer ça me paraîtrait logique est
d'ailleurs très important pour la marque
on devrait avoir la même chose chez
samsung on arrivait au s7 s8 s9 bertrand
x10
mais est-ce que ça serait pas le moment
effectivement de changer des nominations
et proposer quelque chose d'un petit peu
plus grand canal un peu plus rigolo donc
sa valeur va en parler très
régulièrement donc comme d'hab vous
invite à rester connectés à me laisser
des jolies pousse à vous abonner à me
poser toutes vos questions commentaires
suggestions directement en bas dans la
section commentaire qui dédiez qui se
trouve en dessous de l'écran juste là
vous ne marquez tout ça bien évidemment
on reste connectés
soyez sages portez vous bien il vous
avez pas on va revenir très vite avec
plein d'infos hyper croustillantes des
tests de produits des rumeurs plein de
trucs sur la tête et va y avoir plein de
nouveautés je travaille dès maintenant
sur la rentrée du mois de septembre
et croyez-moi ça en rue du bois soyez
sages à bientôt l'ambassade
[Musique]